hey guys i'm philip molina and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 2 home and yeah we can brief it
again Jon Snow lives and of course we
all thought this was gonna happen but
remember this is Game of Thrones
sometimes they hate us and never want us
to be happy so we got a win yay I'm
gonna break everything down point out
some differences from the books and also
just maybe some things you might have
missed on your first viewing also if
you're new to these breakdowns welcome
thank you for joining us I'm a huge Game
of Thrones nerd I've read the books love
the show and these breakdowns treat them
like a podcast of things that I find
interesting about a Game of Thrones
episode I try to find the hidden meaning
and things a lot of times all the times
I think the writers are purposely
putting these things in there to see if
anyone picks up on them sometimes maybe
they're not doing that but I'm still
gonna point it out if I personally find
it interesting so anyway let's dive in
with the opening images so we pick up
where we left bran at the end of season
4 in the cave of the three-eyed Ravens
beyond the wall and small difference in
the books it's actually the three-eyed
crow not Raven but this role is now
being played by Max von Sydow
who you might remember as lor san tekka
from the force awakens and that's
another time he plays an old guy that we
don't know crap about the three-eyed
Raven is this voice that's been reaching
out to Brian since season one but here's
the thing he might have a total complete
backstory that we do know from the books
it's not a 100% definite that this is
the exact same version of the three-eyed
Raven slash thread fro from the books
but I also heard they might not go into
his backstory on the show so just in
case they're not gonna do it on the show
I'm gonna tell you that backstory but if
they do end up doing it on the show it
could end up being spoilers so go ahead
and jump to this time if you don't want
to know anything about the three-eyed
Raven slash three-eyed crow alright
ready let's go okay and remember they
might not be doing this version on the
show this could be a different guy but
if it's the same guy
then the three-eyed Ravens name actually
used to be Brendan rivers and rivers is
one of those bastards last names like
snow stone sand and flowers except he's
not just like any old dirty bastard he's
one of the bastard sons of King Aegon
Targaryen the fourth later when
various Targaryen airs actually fight
against each other in a civil war called
the Blackfyre rebellion but it's a
hundred years before the events of Game
of Thrones
Brendan rivers then served as hand of
the King to King Aerys the first and
make our the first make ours the
great-grandfather of Aerys the second
the Mad King Aerys that you've heard of
so when brendan side loses the war he
gets sent to the wall to accompany his
cousin Aemon Targaryen who's that old
blind maester who died pretty recently
while at the wall Brendan rivers
actually rose to the rank of Lord
Commander but then he went out on one of
these ranging trips and he disappeared
in the forest and it's pretty much
exactly what happened to Jon Snow's
uncle Benjen stark he just goes missing
Brendan was known for using sorcery and
black magic including his abilities as a
warg and as a green seer which are not
the same thing it's harder to kind of
remember these weird words a warg is
someone who controls the minds of
animals and a green seer is someone
whose dreams show the future so he now
lives under this great weirwood tree and
his body's all like tangled up in these
roots and God knows how he eats or he's
as a bathroom I think he's easily over a
hundred years old
again I'm not 100% sure that on the show
they're gonna make it exactly the same
guy on the show they might be like these
thousands of years old or something he's
a totally different guy it's not clear
for sure but this version is Brendan
rivers probably like 115 years old but
maybe older than that either way he's
probably too young for the red woman now
here's the question some of you asked me
you know that bran and the three-eyed
Raven can see through animals and maybe
they can see the future but how do they
see into the past events that they
weren't there for are they organ into
something right now so I think these
opening images are focusing on the roots
of the weirwood tree to give us a clue
as to how these visions are taking place
where woods are these old Staker trees
that have been around for thousands of
years technically they can live forever
if they understood where woods are
considered sacred to the followers of
the old gods and the children of the
forest they believe where woods are the
gods so some green seers can see through
the eyes of a weirwood tree through its
carved face and this is getting weird I
know but because trees have no
sense of time they can't tell where they
exist in time the greenseer looking
through the eyes of the tree is actually
able to see into the past or the present
or the future when looking through a
tree's eyes it said that through the
faces of these trees that's how the old
gods watch over everyone and bear
witness to really important events
that's also what you want to hide from
these trees if you're gonna do anything
terrible anyway one of these weirwood
memories I gives us our opening images
for this episode bran seen a vision of
young ned stark in Winterfell with his
brother Benjen and that's the uncle that
we mentioned before who Jon Snow
followed into the Nights Watch and it's
still currently missing actually Ned
tells benjin shield will ring your head
like a bell you might not remember but
we heard Jon Snow say that exact same
line to Ollie at the beginning of last
season keep your shield open we ring
your head like a bell so this is
something Ned probably passed down to
all of his sons one big takeaway here is
how happy Winterfell looks brand even
says it they were all so happy it's like
a freakin sepia Instagram filter the
colors are warmer we see the white stark
banners are hanging it's like night and
day from the Winterfell of today right
now with its gloomy blue colors and the
grim Bolton flayed man sigil everywhere
remember it's winter in the present day
and this flashback looks a lot like the
kind of summery days of season 1 shout
out to film colorist who can tell part
of a story just by tweaking the colors
but this happy version of Winterfell no
longer exists and this vision is setting
us up for this theme of home as a false
sanctuary we'll get back to that shortly
all these people though they're gone
or dead muttonchops here is a young
Roger Cassell the master of arms who
Theon beheaded but he also trained two
stark children that we know so now we
see also trained Ned and his brothers we
have old nan just being nan one of the
few survivors of this time is Hodor who
we now know is willis and apparently
used to say things other than Hodor and
loathes it when he's going to daughter
lady who total total here's a difference
from the books though there his real
name is waldir not willis but i guess
they didn't want people to confuse him
with the many different people that are
named wall
pray in the books Walter names like most
of his kids Walter - so they changed it
to Willis on the show by the way I have
a feeling that we're gonna get a lot
more of Willis's story and what happened
to his freaking brain in another one of
these flashbacks I think there's gonna
be a lot of the base flashbacks actually
we also see a young Lyanna stark and
it's our first live appearance on the
show and this like show off the entrance
it's almost directly in parallel to the
way arya showed up her little brother in
the first episode Ned Stark would often
say how much are you reminded him of his
sister Lyanna and this is kind of proof
of that wild spirit that they share
lianna's clearly an important figure
from the past and the show wants us to
remember especially considering that
next episode is going to show us the
infamous Tower of joy event which has to
do with her dying the Tower of joy is
this brutal fight that came at the end
of Robert's rebellion back in the day
and it's really tied up in this Jon Snow
true parentage theory that I went over
in the last breakdown watch that if you
want more details on that theory but
focusing on the battle it's Ned Stark
and a gang of badasses fighting again
three other nights one of them is Sir
Arthur Dayne this sword of the morning
who's just one of the greatest nights in
the history of Westeros people always
talked about this night and how he's the
guy that all Knights are graded against
so that battle ends with a dying Liana
asking for a promise from Ned probably
about Jon Snow so this singing here with
this flashback it's all set up in
preparation for this storyline that
we're getting exposed to from the past
very slowly and we're gonna see again
more of it in the next episode with the
Tower of joy I'm so pumped for that
battle and fight it's supposed to be an
amazing fight so I'm really excited
before I move on I want to mention
something else about Liana you've got a
lot of similarities to the Celtic God
Rhiannon and just like a theory about
Liana Rhiannon escaped from an arranged
marriage and had a baby with another man
and that baby's identity was a big ol
secret for a really long time and
Rhiannon was famous for riding on a
white horse that looks a lot like this
one just saying absolutely lead the
flashback the three-eyed Raven warns
brand
trifa beneath the sea but if you stay
too long you drown and bran replies
wasn't drilling
who is who home is the title of this
episode and this moment sets up that
importantthe Matic through-line homes
are meant to be left behind like a baby
bird you have to leave the nest
eventually so you can grow and change
but if you stay too long a home can
become a full sanctuary that traps you
there until you die that false sanctuary
idea along with the concept of drowning
those both come up a lot in this episode
so I'll point those out as we come
across them and real quick this out of
the forest it looks a little funky is
sexually the same character leave they
just redesigned her look new different
cool moving on remember last episode I
pointed out that Davos was able to tell
that thorn is just a big old liar and he
was gonna kill everyone in that room if
he has his way that's being confirmed
right here with all these archers and
people holding crossbows as thorn is
still like yeah come on out it's fine
we're having a party out here actually
these kinds of Lies they play a huge
role in all of the events of Game of
Thrones but I will be getting into that
later luckily this is the episode where
mostly good things happened so we get to
see the wildling giant 1/1 toss around
the Nights Watch Archer like Hulk did to
Loki in The Avengers and while we don't
see Thor nor Ollie die yet which is a
little bit of a bummer but I think they
will there's some poetic justice in the
way that things go down for them cuz
their greatest fear was that Castle
black would fall to the wild lane so
they killed Jon Snow to stop that from
happening and then what happens Castle
black falls to the wildlings
so Thorne and Ollie's own stupid
plotting brought about their greatest
fear good job guys probably gonna die we
leave the wall with a shot of Jon's
corpse and the framing of this shot
makes it look like his Valyrian steel
sword is kind of sticking out of his
chest it's almost like Davos is trying
to pull the sword out of him like he's
trying to reverse all the stabbings that
kill Jon but look at the way the sword
is purposely angled to reflect the light
almost like a prophecy glowing sword
that is held by a prophecy prince that
was promised all of this is done
purposely ppppp I'll talk about it later
though it's always interesting when Game
of Thrones gives us a perspective of in
like onion
street-level commoner like this drunk
that's bragging about having flash
thirsty during her walk of shame
these regular people don't take this
stories as seriously as all of us do so
it's kind of funny to hear them laugh
through these details but Game of
Thrones quickly reminds us that this
story isn't about those people it's
about the people at the top and the
freakshow that surrounds them case in
point Sir Gregor Clegane reanimated in
the books he's become Sir Robert strong
I don't think they're calling him that
on the show I can't tell I don't
remember office like I think it's just
Sir Gregor still but either way it's 15
minutes in and we have seen two giants
turn men into just bloody smears a
really good thing old nan stepped in
before
Hodor did the same thing to little baby
benjin more and more fantastical
elements are coming into this world
Giants and Dragons and resurrected
corpses and it's kind of like the reign
of ordinary men is coming to an end and
at the end I'm going to explain why I
think that's happening but moving on
Cersei holding the loose thread from her
morning gown is a symbol for how her or
Murli regal life and power it's all
unraveling it's hard to feel like you're
in control and very queen like when you
can't do anything to prevent your kids
from dying her fancy clothing which just
represents her status as a Queen Regent
it can't do anything about this witch's
prophecy and adding to her power coming
undone Tommen has just ordered the
Kingsguard to trap her inside her home
which is another case of a home becoming
a false sanctuary it's actually more
like a cage and then Jaime's father-son
moment with Tommen in the set it kind of
reminds us actually about the Kingslayer
just not having really any respect for
these sacred institutions because
remember the last time that it was here
he had that awkward kind of forced sex
with Cersei next to their sons dead body
and this time he threatens to spill the
blood of the Westeros tacloban to the
Pope so Jaime is another example of one
of these ordinary men that spits in the
face of the gods and breaks his vows but
that's part of that thing I'm going to
explain at the end the high Sparrow then
explains that the eye stones are
supposed to teach us not to fear death
because our eyes closed in one life and
they open in the next that runs parallel
to brain situation where he closed his
eyes in season one and it marked the
death of his childhood but he opens his
eye
now to a new life as a war again as a
greenseer then in marine we get this
shot of the harpy statue that used to be
at the top of the pyramid before was
torn down at the beginning of last
season but what exactly does that statue
mean keep in mind the harpy is the
symbol of the old ghiscari empire I
think of Essos it's just like the dragon
is a symbol for House Targaryen
so harpy statues had appeared in the
cities that Danny had conquered and if
you notice harpy statues have chains and
iron collars in their talons which
represent the slavery tradition that
Dany has now overthrown but now we see
that the statue literally didn't go
anywhere it's been sitting there this
whole time just lingering in the shadows
and that represents that this concept of
slavery and that tradition it also
didn't go anywhere it's sitting there
it's remnants at least in the people of
murine just kind of in the shadows
cheering then gives his new small
council a lecture about dragons and
captivity suffering stunted growth and
dying and it's based on what he's read
in the book Aegon dragons it's kind of
like well so what supposedly happens to
kittens that were raised in jars it's
not a real thing but they're called
bonsai kittens look it up it's
hilariously adorable but more
importantly kind of like bran and Cersei
that's another example of how a home
that's been created like this cave for
these dragons can actually become a
false sanctuary if you stay too long
it's more like you're imprisoned there
and it'll eventually kill you and even
though he's just referring to the
Targaryen dragons his lesson also
applies to the Targaryen themselves one
of Danny's shortcomings as a ruler of
murine was her tendency to stay shut
away inside of her pyramid or her safe
haven away from her people so they kind
of stopped trusting her that's not too
different from her father than Mad King
Aerys who spent his final days holed up
in the red keep burning people alive
until you know Jaime Lannister killed
them both the Targaryen and their
dragons need to leave their false
sanctuaries and while Daenerys has done
that in a way we'll get to that soon but
Tyrion unchaining these dragons in the
dungeon it kind of points something
interesting out he's pretty much ruling
marine right now and he's using all his
wisdom from Westeros and it's making him
a pretty good ruler like no offense to
Dany but she's the mother of dragons on
the breaker of chains and she's the one
that
them up in a way terian now is the new
breaker of chains at least in this
moment and Turing's childhood
fascination with dragons that raises the
question why are the dragons so friendly
to Tyrion a lot of you are asking me
about another theory that could be a
spoiler so heads up skip to this time
it's possible that Tyrion is actually
the bastard son of the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen and Tywin Lannister's wife
Johanna that would give another reason
why Tywin so frequently declared it
would also make Tyrion brother to
Daenerys and if that theory about Jon
Snow is true it would make him Jon
Snow's uncle and it would make sense why
dragons don't hate him cuz he's part
Targaryen and if you remember when Danny
Way back when went into the house of the
undying and she saw these like images
and they were kind of like prophesies in
the books she sees way more when she's
there she looks into a room see a man
with silver hair and he's holding a
newborn and he's talking about a
three-headed dragon so silver haired
people tend to be Targaryen and the book
is full of references to this moment
where the Targaryen dragon is said to
need three heads as in three leaders
some people take that to mean that there
are three young Targaryen people out
there left in the world and that could
correspond to our three main
protagonists of this series Daenerys Jon
Snow if that theory is true and Tyrion
this theory is true and Tyrion did hit
it off with both Dany and Jon almost
immediately and then he walks into a
dungeon with two Bish's dragons and he
comes out completely unscathed which
definitely makes this Tyrion Targaryen
theory pretty plausible there's another
reason why all three of these characters
are sort of linked and why it feels like
it could be headed toward a situation
where Jon and Daenerys KO rule Westeros
with Tyrion serving as a hand to the
king and queen Ben but I will get to
this other connection that they have at
the end let's move on arya faces one
last test before Jack and Hegar takes
her back in if Akane the man will let
her sleep under a roof tonight a promise
of shelter or home but Arya knows that
this roof to sleep under is just another
false sanctuary in this backwards world
where homes are not safe places and
weddings are red she knows better and
remains true to having no name and by
leaving her home behind her she can now
move forward the next scene shows us
Winterfell another home that would have
meant death if the residents have stayed
and obviously it does mean that for
Roose Bolton now one interesting thing
to point out here Ramsay's betrayal
comes in the form of a hug and a stab
just like how Roose is betrayal of Robb
Stark came with a hug and a stab too now
if a hug seems like a weird choice for
Ramsay in the first place it does kind
of make sense actually because there's
another little mystical moment here
Ramsay knows he has to kill his father
as soon as possible but his father is
famous for wearing protective chainmail
almost all the time so this hug gives
Ramsay a chance to check and see if
Roose was wearing his famous chainmail
and once he'd confirmed that he's not he
knew now was the time to make his move
also when the former Lord Bolton
references Ramsay acting like a Mad Dog
as if it's a bad thing he clearly
doesn't get Ramsay because a moment
later Ramsay makes it very clear if he
had to choose between being like a Mad
Dog
or being this noble true son of house
Bolton well he's gonna pick Mad Dogs
because pitted against each other Mad
Dogs beat Nobles babies every time and I
know if you're thinking that's an unfair
fight bad dogs and babies it's more the
representation of true noble birth and
innocent and not willing to do what it
takes like a Mad Dog is willing to do
what it takes so I do mean yes literally
a dog's be babies in fights but I also
mean figuratively Ramsay's like yeah
I'll always pick Mad Dog ever noble
innocent baby people also I'm really
glad the camera stayed on Ramsay here
it's clearly a choice so that we don't
have to watch this gruesome carnage that
Ramsay so clearly loves watching and
personally I don't think I could have
handled seeing Walda and her baby eat
all those dogs Ramsay's power grab might
seem reckless at first but it's clear
that the new Lord Karstark was in on it
and along with the manderlys and the
umbers potentially if he would have
enough support to hold the north so the
teaser for the next episode showed that
Lord umber has a gift for you
for Ramsay I feel like that could be
Rickon stark who was last seen headed to
the umbers with
Osia and I've been predicting that the
Starks are going to bounce back this
season so I really am hoping that if it
is Rickon he's not like immediately
killed maybe next week I'll talk about
why Rick Ansari is gonna be a big
letdown but it will be a letdown on
purpose that sounds ridiculous but I'll
explain it in next week's episode and
then after Sansa finds out that Arya is
still alive we get Theon and he says he
intends to go homes though his home
another fall sanctuary buddy it's
definitely not safe we haven't seen old
Bale on great joy in the Iron Islands
since season 3 but here he is at his
home and it's a dangerous place his
death actually marks the official end of
the war of the five kings
that's what Melisandre was doing way
back when with all those leeches she was
asking for the deaths of the kings
Joffrey is dead Renly Baratheon who's
dead Robb Stark who's dead
and now baylon Greyjoy said
unfortunately the fifth King Stannis is
also dead and that's the one she was in
support of the woops
maybe she like bleached too harsh anyway
this marks a difference on the books
because baylon in the books he dies way
earlier like right around the red
wedding and when he dies it's just the
storm that overtakes them like literally
by himself that's it it's kind of lame
actually there is a rumor in the books
that it could have been a faceless man
that showed up and like pushed him over
but it's not confirmed it kind of left
it it just being the water and storm
that kills him so I actually very much
preferred the choice on the show of
having his brother kill him it's more
personal and interesting and in a way it
still is the storm that kills him I am
strong this new character by the way in
case you don't know it's you're on
Greyjoy it's baylin's younger brother
he's a different brother from Aaron
Greyjoy who's damp hair the drowned God
priest - we'll see in a little bit in
the books
Euron is a cunning captain with an
eyepatch it's one of the cooler
characters actually in the series
definitely one of the cooler characters
of the Greyjoy story and I know some of
you couldn't follow the conversation
that was happening and who this person
was and what he was talking about
everybody TJ tweeted at me what was the
bridge seen so here's what was going on
there here's what they were saying
you're on
is a maniacal road captain with a huge
eco and he considers himself village
round god I am the drone gone like not a
worshipper of it but the town got it
himself and he went kind of crazy
some people say because of a storm that
scared him a lot and drove him mad other
people say it for different reasons
the mouse keep you from jumping out but
he cuts out his entire crews tongues to
keep them from talking about how crazy
he went he decided and now you're on is
saying that he intends to replace his
brother as king of the Iron Islands
sorry if you're like yeah I knew all
this but enough people were tweeting
about confusion about what exactly I
have to know that I thought it was worth
explaining but also trying to kill each
other on a narrow rope bridge during the
storm it's not the warmest way for
brothers to meet each other and it just
reminds me like I don't know which
Greyjoy family reunion was worse this
one or when Dionne reunited with Yara
you can tell your grandchildren about
this night I don't imagine it'll be a
story fit for children that was gross by
the way remember in the last episode
breakdown hai mentioned there was a
family who really knows boats really
well that could help replace Marines
burned up fleet this is who I was
talking about could these people come to
Daenerys is aid maybe I don't know you
tell me what you think moving on we see
air on damp hair which by the way a lot
of people pronounce it differently they
say damp fear george RR martin admits
that he probably should have put a
hyphen in the name but it is pronounced
damp hair because his hair is always get
involved amp he's a priest of the
drowned god he's bailing other brother
who we saw baptized Theon in season two
he tells Yara that the new king is gonna
be chosen by a Kingsmoot throne is not
yours to swear upon not unless the Kings
moot chooses you and you might not have
paid attention to that moment but that's
actually kind of a big deal at Kings
moon so what is that the Kings Moo is an
ancient election ceremony in the Iron
Islands that used to be the way the
Ironborn chose a new king but in recent
years the Greyjoy family has just ruled
the island but Dampier calls the kings
moot because he doesn't see bail on
having an obvious air anymore iran's
reputation is like super shady dion is
still missing
and Yara is a woman and that is still
kind of an issue for them so they gotta
go with the Kings move which involves
captains of ships picking champions to
vouch for them and then they have to
impress everyone with all the riches
they plundered the other interesting
thing about the Kings moot though that
kind of makes the seed of the King just
up for grabs for anyone it really is
just up to who can get the most support
during the Moot which is basically the
same ideas is open convention that a lot
of people are talking about in real life
here that they would want to use to
prevent Donald Trump from becoming the
Republican nominee but that's not gonna
happen this is kind of the closest that
Westeros even gets to democracy these
open elections they're one of the only
good things to come out of the Iron
Islands that and very unconventional
family reunions and this whole part of
the episode was a key reminder of the
religion of the Ironborn their God is
the drowned God and their prayer is what
is dead may never die the rises again
harder and stronger Ironborn right
except they actually take that pretty
literally the Ironborn actually
practiced this form of resuscitation
they literally drown people in salt
water and then bring them back to life
because as they see it if you died from
drowning already then you don't need to
worry about dying anymore so you're
probably gonna become a badass warrior
cuz you don't worry about that even
though we know it's just like oh good
thing somebody was good at CPR but
anyway what's interesting that right
after damp hair references warriors who
come back from death we go to Davos
wondering if that can happen with Jon
Snow
I assume you noob why I'm here and
actually Davos is kind of speaking for
everybody watching the show when he
talks to Melisandre and he's asking like
uh could you just like I mean you're
magic right can't you just like you
please use your magic and bring him back
and just like we saw the last episode
Melisandre is totally bundled up next to
the fire the Lord of Light swarms it's
wholly gone from her so she's hid this
faith rock bottom and specifically the
power of Resurrection is something that
she's always kind of weird about if you
remember back in season 3 she was
totally skeptical that this drunk
lowlife freeze-thaw ro Sameer was able
to bring back beric Dondarrion six times
actually but if you look back at that
moment
Thoros talks about how he also was Chi
at faiths rock bottom when the Lord of
Light let him perform his miracle he
admits that he was a drunk that didn't
really believe in these words and right
then is when it actually works so that
could be a requirement to a red priest
or priestess kind of being able to gain
these powers also by the way speaking of
a successful resurrection
check out the christ imagery here with
John's body he's got the puncture wounds
he's got a white loincloth thing and
come I mean he just looks like Jesus
right this episode actually aired on
Easter Sunday for Orthodox Christians
which is a day that celebrates Jesus's
resurrection from the deck that could be
a coincidence
but I'm calling it this is Jesus snow
they're doing it on purpose there's
probably gonna be more Jesus stuff
coming forward in the next couple
episodes I bet people love doing that
with resurrection storyline see Glen
Melisandre even kind of acts like a Mary
Magdalene figure who is famous for being
the woman who cleans Jesus's feet and
she's also famous for how sad she got
right before he was resurrected like the
word maudlin comes from Mary Magdalene
sadness and tears over Jesus's death but
anyway we just saw that from Alessandro
- a lot of parallels anyway Melisandre
then chants in Valyrian and while we
don't get any subtitles my guess is that
she's using the same words that Thoreau
said back when it's a skewed version of
the common Lord of Light prayer - what
Goodwin and then lo and behold
Melisandre is rock-bottom humble prayer
does the trick the camera lingers on
John and BAM eyes open snows back baby
fun connection to point out here this
was the second episode of season 6 and
the second episode of season 1 ended
with a parallel image where bran Starks
eyes reopened from his sort of death
coma thing so Jon Snow's back from the
dead and thank God the show did it at
least somewhat early in the season
instead of waiting to the end but does
this successful resurrection mean that
the Lord of Light then is obviously the
one true God not exactly because we've
seen all the other gods be magical in
different ways to the tree gods allow
brand to see through time the many-faced
God can transform your face the drowned
God brings drowned men back to life
though it might just be like the Lord of
CPR again
but assuming it really was the Lord of
light that brought back John snow then
that probably does make John the Prince
to his promise that I talked about
earlier with the glowing sword being
light bringer azure ahyes sword that he
uses those aura high is the princess
promise by the way and if you don't know
who is aura highes I'll just go do
really fast
Asura hi was an ancient warrior who used
light bringer to fight up the Nemesis of
the Lord of Light the great other he's
like the top white Walker of his time
Melisandre is obsessed with finding azor
Ahai reborn version to fulfill the
prophecy of him coming back to defeat
the returning White Walkers she used to
think it was Stannis Baratheon but he's
dead
and meanwhile we saw Jon Snow obliterate
a white Walker with his possible
Lightbringer sword last season at
hardhome
and something interesting from the books
it goes a lot more into Melisandre and
Jon Snow in azor Ahai but there's this
chapter of a dance with dragons where
Melisandre keeps thinking to herself
about these prayers she's doing to see
an image of azor Ahai and she talked
about the god only shows her snow and
then a few chapters later john hears her
say that all she keeps seeing in her
visions is snow and it kind of is
purposely written away where you might
think that it's like white snow and
she's just not seeing anything but one
of the times in the book they use a
capital S when she says she sees his
snow so she obviously would mean that
when she is looking for his or 'hi in
her vision she sees Jon Snow I'm gonna
bring up more thoughts on Jon Snow in
just a second but let's talk about these
closing images remember that the episode
is titled home I've been talking a lot
about the ideas of false sanctuaries
right where each of the major characters
this episode realizing that the concept
of home is not the safe haven that they
thought it was Tyrion informs us about
how the home for the Dragons is actually
killing them the three-eyed raven warns
brand that staying too long in what
brand calls home would drown brand
Cersei is imprisoned inside the red keep
which is her home both Roose Bolton and
Balon Greyjoy get murdered by family
inside of the safety of their own homes
and Arya recognizes that the promise of
home is a trick but this is all
counterintuitive right shouldn't home be
safe well not in this world and that's
because of the actions that ordinary men
have taken
deceitful men I like Jaime Lannister
Walder Frey Alliser thorne they've all
blatantly broken
our vowels and broken their oaths and
done it all in the faces of the gods
that they swore those oaths to in the
world of Game of Thrones in the recent
history of the show in the books these
people have begun taking sacred oaths
and almost immediately spitting in the
face of them so for a really long time
in Westeros men kind of kept their word
they made their vows to gods and they
honored them and there was a respect for
the laws that those gods established not
anymore the whole story actually started
with this huge breaking of an oath the
one between a married man and woman she
swears to love and honor him
Littlefinger though convinced Lysa to
poison Jon Arryn at the start of the
series poison her husband that's just
one of the many breakings of marriage
oats during this time period famously
yeah the red wedding but even before
this whole story
Rhaegar forces destruction of Liana and
Roberts promised betrothal and Cersei
breaks her oath of marriage to Robert
which she conspires to have him killed
and also specifically about the red
wedding but before it Robb breaks his
oath to marry one of the Frey daughters
was pledged to marry one of you and I
broke that vow which causes the red
wedding in the first place and going
specifically into the red wedding
there's the other big oath that's broken
there with they break the laws of
hospitality there are so many of these
other oaths and vows that have been
broken in this period of Westeros
include thorne killing his Lord
Commander olaria overthrowing her leader
Ramsay now kills his own kin
he's your brother I prefer being an only
child
yada-yada I could go on forever but
basically sacred oaths to the gods are
being blatantly ignored and broken right
now and we can't expect the gods to just
take that laying down so that's what I
meant by the gods have decided the reign
of man is over it's time to bring back
the monsters and the magic of the gods
they've bringing back White Walkers and
Dragons have come back from extinction
and demon babies it's kind of like Sodom
and Gomorrah where these gods are like
these people are all jerks why don't we
just like pull them all down and start
over
clean slate maybe the next generation of
man if there is one will learn to stop
breaking all of their freaking oats
and by the way the next episodes title
is Oathbreaker but if you're wondering
yeah yeah basically everyone breaks
oaths on the show is there's a couple
people I guess that don't yeah those
characters
important the ones that don't I think
they're the ones that are finally being
rewarded and I think they're also the
ones that happen to have been smart
enough to leave their homes before those
fall sanctuaries could overtake them
Daenerys ran from the West as a baby and
instead of returning to the home of the
Targaryen she continued to go east like
the prophecy says she has to before she
can go west John Snow started the series
pretty quickly choosing to leave his
home for the wall and even beyond that
and third I kind of mentioned this
earlier but tyrion is now a run away
from home having also gone he's and
before you say wait tyrion did break a
sacred oath he killed his father I'll
remind you there's a possibility that
Tywin is not Tyrians real father
so that oath is not really broken so our
three heroes they're some of the only
honorable people in this world and
they're being smiled upon by the gods
they've not only lived up to their oath
that they've made to people but they've
used these opportunities in these
journeys to learn more about what they
need to do to become better people and
they've grown and just as we're getting
into the final act of our story and
every story is a version of the hero's
journey now our three heroes are changed
for the better so that means it's
finally time for them to do what every
good hero does return home Daenerys and
Tyrion are gonna go back to Westeros
John's gonna go back to Winterfell I'm
guessing all of that Oh also really
quick if you listen to that theory about
Tyrion earlier that some people skipped
you also know the other big reason why
this three people might be connected
okay so a few lingering questions one is
this gonna be the same Jon Snow I don't
expect him to be brain dead and mute
like Khal Drogo and the mountain after
they were brought back to life but beric
Dondarrion said that he loses a part of
himself every time he's brought back so
how do we think resurrections gonna
affect Jon my guess is his like view of
the world is probably gonna be pretty
crappy right now but do you have any
other ideas of how Jon might be changed
by his resurrection to in the books
wargs are known for being transported
into their animals when they die but
it's really hard to tell if that
actually happened here with Jon I know
that you might not think jon is a warg
remember in the books all the Starks are
kind of wards so do you think John could
have warg into ghosts last video I broke
down that the Starks family connection
to their direwolves is very strong and
lot of people think that John's
consciousness maybe could have
transferred over to ghosts the second
that he died but in the show it seems
kind of more like the Lord of Light just
like jammed his soul back into his body
may be unrelated to ghosts just one or
do you think ghosts had any role in that
resurrection and three if I'm right
about Jon Snow Daenerys Targaryen and
Tyrion Lannister all being currently
smiled upon by the gods then you could
explain that Jon's resurrection is a
miracle granted to him by the gods and
Daenerys being unburned by fire her
ability to do that is something she's
been gifted by the gods but then that
would mean that Tyrion still might have
a miracle coming his way what do you
think Tyrians miracle could be let me
know what you think about all of those
in the comments and also if you haven't
seen already check out our breakdown of
last episode I explained some of the Jon
Snow theories they're a little more
clearly if I miss something here it
might be in that video but also if
there's anything else you want to point
out or talk to me about feel free to hit
me up on twitter at fimo on facebook I
have little longer discussions usually
it's a facebook.com/ slash fimo nose and
then if you want to know just about like
when videos come out that kind of stuff
always follow at new rock stars on
Twitter if you like this video please
you can hit the like button but more
importantly I think you should share it
with other people who like Game of
Thrones also subscribe to new rockstars
so you can keep up with all of these
videos we do for Game of Thrones and
everything else so that's it let's move
the conversation to Twitter and Facebook
I'll catch you guys next week see ya bye